[Music]
the house has voted to impeach president
trump once again both democrat and
republican members fiercely debated
today exactly one week after the violent
assault on the capitol building
where five people died this is the first
time in history that a president has
been impeached twice good afternoon
thank you so much for joining us at four
i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casarez unlike the
first impeachment this time 10
republicans
joined with democrats natalie brand has
the breaking update
from capitol hill
with bipartisan support the house of
representatives has voted for a second
time to impeach president donald trump
he must go
he is a clear and present danger to the
nation
that we all love passions flared during
the floor debate over charges the
president
incited last week's violent and deadly
assault on the u.s
capitol the cameras of history are
rolling
we must act we are on an absolute race
to the bottom
the third ranking house republican liz
chaney and a group of her gop
colleagues voted yes these articles of
impeachment are flawed
but i will not use process as an excuse
over the past
24 hours at least 10 senate republicans
have come out
against impeaching president trump most
of them citing
issues with process and timing senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell said
today he's not
made a final decision on how he will
vote and will listen to the arguments
when they're presented to the senate but
a spokesman said he will not
reconvene the senate for an emergency
session meaning a trial likely won't
take place
until after president-elect joe biden's
inauguration
next week speaker pelosi has already
named the nine impeachment managers who
will act as prosecutors
in and around the capitol large groups
of armed national guard members and law
enforcement remain
on high alert natalie brand cbs news
capitol hill
some of our state's representatives
speaking out in support of the decision
to impeach
president trump congressman stephen
horsford says quote donald trump incited
insurrection against america and
attempted to overturn the will of the
people
we must send a clear message that
committing sedition disqualifies a
president from serving another day
in office representative dina titus adds
quote president trump incited an attack
on the u.s capitol building the people
who work there
vice president mike pence in the united
states of america
the case for impeachment is overwhelming
for more than three decades i taught u.s
history as a professor of government and
politics
there has never been a president who is
so unfit to serve
i voted to impeach president trump
because he has a clear and present
danger to this country